and here he is joining us here on the
rich eisen show in his 11th season
in the national football league getting
his first career play-off snaps and boy
were they important ones the men who
helped the chiefs
to get back to the afc championship game
for the third straight year he is chad
henny
how are you chad great how you doing
right i am doing better for talking to
you what was sunday like for you
what was that like for you i mean
definitely a moment to remember
um obviously you know you never want
those circumstances to happen with
patrick
but um that's why i'm here you know you
stay prepared for these moments
and uh you just put your best foot out
there and uh
make some plays if you can and uh
hopefully
you come out victorious how do you stay
ready for something like that chad
how i mean how does that work i think
yeah i mean i think over the years i
mean i just push myself to stimulate
myself each and every week try to find
an edge
and uh you know study the game plan like
you're a starter each and every week
and uh never take a backseat you know
push patrick
if i see something help him out uh but
at the same time
uh just clue into my uh keys and
everything on their defense that i can
go out there and attack uh once
i have an opportunity did you see
patrick get up looking woozy
uh and know that okay this is it is that
how you learned
you were going in yeah i mean uh i i
felt like he he got the first down so i
was looking i was like all right we're
good and then when he kind of buckled
i was like oh man then they're like all
right get your helmet just get out there
get warmed up and you're in it's a quick
decision and
there's not a lot of thinking that goes
into it you just get out there and you
know
you hopefully get in there and put some
points on the board and then of all
moments for you to be put in i mean this
is
forget about free playoffs and all that
stuff obviously that that's that that's
that's one thing but a short yardage
must have
situation and then they call for you to
flip it i mean
what did you think of when the play call
came in
yeah i mean uh you know there's a couple
short yardage plays that we have each
and every week and
same thing you know you just you study
those plays you know the plays uh by
heart
and you know when they come in there you
you just executing the best of your
ability and
felt confident in our our call there and
uh
you know we made a great play there no i
know that but i mean what it
walk me through what what goes in your
head uh obviously uh you
you know the plays but again they're
they're it's like okay
you're you're going to get your your uh
your feet wet right away
with a play like that yeah but i think
uh the the first thing is getting the
snap
you know right you're going there you
fumble the snap you look like
a dip you know you can't
you can't really go out there and you
know put your best foot forward there
but uh you know first of all get the
snap
and second of all you know look the
pitch in make sure the pitch gets to the
running back
and uh yeah i've done a couple of those
in my career yes you have
it's been a while but um you know just
make the best of it
no i chad look i know you are a veteran
you're prepared look i
i i watched you play your first snap in
college you know i've been
i've been following you for ever and a
day so i know you're
you're ready for it but then again i
mean you you're thrown in it
and then the play does have a certain uh
aspect
of trickiness to it and i just thought
that that
that was we're all talking about
obviously the the fourth down play call
to seal the deal but
the way it started i has kind of gotten
lost in it is all i'm kind of saying
yeah yeah absolutely and uh you know at
the same thing is just
you know go out there you know look the
pitch and get the snap
and uh let the other guys do the work
for you and then of course
you know chad henny here uh on the rich
eisen show uh fresh off of the win
over the cleveland browns yesterday in
arrowhead uh where'd the wheels come
from
chad did not know you had that in you in
that third and long to set up the fourth
and short to seal the deal
where'd the wheels come from yeah well
you know when i was a
chubby little guy in miami and uh
michigan
going through i was i was actually a
track athlete in high school i'm not
going to say i'm the fastest guy but um
you know i've swimmed down a little bit
over the years and stayed in shape
and um you know when opportunity comes i
can still move a little bit i'm not
going to say i'm the greatest out there
but
when the time is needed i can you know
put my head down and run are you saying
you're on the ch4 system
is that what you're saying chad you're
on the ch4 system
i don't know about that i mean i was on
the 4x1 in high school
and uh we had a pretty good team and i
always had it in me i
like i said i'm not the fastest person
but if if
times needed just like you know you see
matt ryan out there he's running around
too we're in the same draft class
you know some of the old guys can still
run around a little bit okay
you cracked five at the 40 at the
combine chat that's a big thing to do
back in certainly in the uh in the late
aughts nobody
was really doing that sort of thing at
the combine
yeah i mean good i don't know what i ran
but definitely you did crack the five i
think
might have ran a little faster than me
but i'm not gonna say anything about
that
well you know what he did uh wind up
being number one overall
you know he wound up being a number one
uh first overall pick for the uh
for the um the dolphins back in the day
so let's uh let's walk through
that fourth down call when it came in
walk me through your
your mindset getting that call to seal
the deal and the execution of it
chad yeah so we talk about uh all our
fourth down plays on saturday night uh
patrick has his eye of mine and then we
kind of you know bring it together with
the coaches and
if they like it you know we make those
calls and uh that was one of our
fourth and one calls the one that i
liked and uh what the coaches liked
so you know felt very confident in it
you know luckily they were in man
coverage
and uh tyree graham a heckler out real
quick and just had to put the ball
in a spot for him to get the first down
and then how did that feel to you
seriously it's chad i mean this has been
a long time coming for you to
have an opportunity like this uh with a
team like this
in a moment like this and you come
through what is it like for you chad
honey seriously
well i mean it meant the world i mean
all the opportunities that this team has
given me you know taking me a super bowl
one super bowl last year uh brought me
in in 2018
and uh you know it was just great for
them to give me something and i can give
them something back
chad henny chiefs quarterback here on
the rich eyes and shoot
rich eisen show a few more minutes left
uh with him here
so what is it like walk me through what
it's like to be in the
quarterback room with mahomes and you
say your your role as support
for a kid who's gotten so much
thrown at him and him being so
successful at it
um what walk me through the process put
me as a fly on that wall
chad for you yeah yeah i mean which is
great
uh you know in 2018 it's patrick's first
year
uh starting you know officially
throughout and um
you know coming in obviously everybody
knows how talented he is
uh arm mobility creating plays
but a lot of things that people don't
understand is his attention to detail
and his preparation his note-taking is
exceptional
uh the way he looks at the at the film
um you know and he's a quick learner
he sees something on film and he can you
know repeat it and just regurgitate it
in his mind
so quickly um it's almost like a
photographic memory
and he's been great uh and he stayed the
same since i've been here day one
and he's only gotten better and he'll
continue to keep getting better
how is he right now as you and i are
chatting chad honey
yeah i mean i saw him this morning and
uh he's in good spirits
obviously he'll go through all the
protocols and uh we'll see what happens
in the next couple days
but he's in good spirits and uh you know
we're hopeful for him
jimmy give me uh a good andy reid story
what's your favorite andy reed story
story since being around him chad give
me one i don't know i mean i
he's just so i mean
he's very humble uh he appreciates
everybody around him
but he's very humorous um you know his
his jokes that he can spit out i think
the best thing about him is he creates
these
little names for everybody and uh
you know one would be you know clyde
uh a running back saying you know he's
mighty mouth
and he comes up with these descriptions
of
people and things and it's it's just
hilarious when he comes out
they'll just pull it out and be like hey
mighty mouse and you never heard it and
you're like
who the heck is mighty mouse he's like
yeah you clyde
and then you think you look at clyde and
he does look kind of like a mouse
and uh he just keeps the air you know
thin and you know healthy and it's just
it's fun to be around because he's so
funny and uh
you know he's easy to talk to and does
he have a name for you
do you have a name an andy reid name for
you
i don't know i mean he's just been
calling me the old man the last couple
years and stuff old man but uh he hasn't
really come up with
a lot with me uh you know our other
running back
darwin thompson he calls him termites so
he's always making jokes about chopping
on wood
um but there's a lot of a lot of guys
out there it's funny all right before i
let you go chad let's have a moment for
us here
chad do you know do you know um who who
took victory knees yesterday
in playoff games chad do you know the
two quarterbacks who took victory knees
yesterday
in playoff games that would yeah i mean
uh obviously
uh tom brady uh definitely one of them
and uh
myself that's right two michigan guys
that is correct
pretty cool and and and two guys who
played for lloyd carr
you know i don't know where john navarro
yesterday was but he was taking a
victory knee wherever he was
um so i mean
i i've always wanted to ask you this
question so i now have this opportunity
you were and this is unfortunate but yet
fortunate on that day
the last michigan quarterback to beat
urban meyer you beat him
in that capital one bowl um when he was
the head coach of florida
you outdueled tim tebow the current
michigan
running backs coach mike hart had a
couple scores that day and it was
lloyd's last game
and rich rodriguez was standing on that
sideline what was
was that awkward was that just an
awkward day for everybody
uh to do that on behalf of lloyd
yeah i mean to be honest i mean now
really didn't think much about it just
because we were so uh engulfed in the
game and
about lloyd but i think even the weeks
leading up to it
it was it was different and um you know
not knowing rich
you know you know his um you know spread
offense and with pat white
and all that but i didn't know a lot
about him just knew that it was going to
be a different system a different look
for michigan
but you know we were more worried about
lloyd and setting him off on the right
way
he's given us so much and especially to
our program
a true leader and a guy that really
cares about the student athlete
but not just that though chad because so
much you do point out what was being
said by all of us
uh watching michigan football was you
know here comes rich rod spread offense
but you you guys did that that day
against florida
i mean you winged it around for 373
yards passing
on that day you found manningham who
wound up making one of the biggest
catches in super bowl history a couple
years later
if not two years it was two years later
i mean you were funny ham and arrington
all over the place
did did lloyd say let's open it up
before i get out of here that's three
yards in the cloud of dust everyone can
stick it
did that happen well i think yeah i mean
i think uh i mean obviously we knew
lloyd was going to be gone but
maybe some of those assistant coaches uh
still wanted to stick around michigan so
you know show that we could uh know that
we could actually
open it up and show rich rod that hey
our coaches are adaptable as well
and uh you know can do a different
system rather than profile offense did
brady
reach out to you while you were at
school there did you have any
relationship with him that uh might
actually still
uh linger today chad yeah i mean it was
it was very early on and
um you know just a couple key moments
um but it was just pretty much just be
yourself
go out there you know lead the team and
it was very short
and you know we had a couple
conversations when i was in miami
after the games and i always appreciate
him
i always you know admired the way he's
played the game represented the
university of michigan
and uh you know the quarterback club
here in the nfl
chad congrats on the win yesterday man
and uh
and getting your team to the next um
next level
getting them to the afc championship
game good luck preparing for the bills
and let's
let's stay in touch congrats on that big
w yesterday for you
appreciate it rich you got it that is
chad henny the kansas city chiefs here
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here